giant ice spiders don't like spiders
delicious frog eggs
and jet packs gone wrong episode 2 of
the latest season of the mandalorian is
here and we got tons of stuff to cover
including the origins of those cave
spiders where the mandalorian is off to
next
and just how bad dr mandible is at sabac
so strap on in and make sure to like and
subscribe because here
we go we are back on tatooine the two
suns in the horizon
hinting at midday it's a contrast to
last episode where we had that huge
reveal of boba fett
set against two setting suns
unfortunately there is
no boba fett this episode and they may
stretch that out even further
kind of like what they did in episode 5
of season 1
giving us only a hint of him also
missing any mention of moth
gideon it's been two episodes since he
wielded that dark saber
and while i like these self-contained
episodes i'm hoping the show will pick
up some more steam with the overall
story i should also mention this episode
is directed by peyton reed who you may
remember directed ant-man with boba
fett's mandalorian armor
safely acquired from cobb vanth mando
makes his way through the blistering
tatooine desert on his way to the port
city of mos
eisley you know this same one from a new
hope of course things
never seem to go well for mando as he's
lured into a trap by a group of ragtag
bounty hunters what's really interesting
here is that they say
get the child not the besker armor not
his spoils from killing the crate dragon
the child these men have been assigned
to track down our precious baby yoda and
yes i know it's not actually baby yoda
just everyone seems to call them that
but the question is who sent them it
could be boba fett but i lean more
towards it being moff gideon this dude
probably has a huge reward for whoever
can retrieve the child for him mando
makes quick work of these thugs and i
love how the show is able to showcase
his gadgets in new and
interesting ways like how he uses his
grappling line to grab hold of his
weapon to knock out two of the bad guys
that's pretty cool the remaining bounty
hunter who's like three feet tall
threatens to hurt baby yoda and once
again the mandalorian expresses how far
he's willing to go to protect him
if you put one mark on him there's no
place you will be able to hide from me
he trades his jetpack in exchange for
the child which of course
completely backfires for this greedy
bounty hunter you may also notice a
mando still covered in the acidic slime
from the krait dragon that armor was
able to protect him from the acid and
may offer some clues as to how boba fett
survived the sarlacc pit in return of
the jedi we know from last episode that
krait dragons eat
sarlaccs i've done tattooing my whole
life there's no such
thing as an abandoned store like pit
there is if you eat the sarlacc
and that sarlaccs take years to digest
their victims
as you are slowly digested over a
thousand years
what if one of these dragons ate the
sarlacc boba fett was in and he was able
to escape
out of that dragons similar to how the
mandalorian was able to escape
back at the cantina mando meets up with
pele motto who's having a friendly game
of sabbac with dr mandible savak is the
card game lando carissian plays in solo
and
speaking of solo you can see the blaster
mark from a new hope in the concept art
for this scene at the end of the episode
dr mandible was also seen five episodes
ago when mando first made his appearance
on tatooine
there's also a frog person in that
episode now i'm not that great at
telling frog people apart so i'll let
you decide if that's the same frog lady
mando later joins up with fun fact frog
lady is played by the same performance
artist who did all of queel's work in
season 1.
over some delicious crate meet pelly
tells mando that this mysterious
passenger needs safe travel to the
estuary moon planet of trask
located one system over from tatooine in
exchange she'll tell him where a group
of mandalorians have been hiding out
perhaps one that escaped navarro it
makes me wonder
if there are indeed mandalorians hiding
there will he be reunited with the
armorer and if she'll be able to fix
that old boba fett armor the passenger
has requested a travel sublight meaning
not light speed apparently traveling any
faster will destroy the eggs she's
trying to fertilize
if only she knew the biggest threat to
her eggs would be baby yoda
although the episode focuses heavily on
the child we don't get to see him use
much of his powers like we've seen in
the past
the closest we get is him moving the
eggs in their liquid tank
manda wakes up to an incoming call from
two new republic x-wing starfighters
one is held by captain carson tiva who
for you canadians out there might
remember the actor from a show called
kim's convenience
the other is trapper wolf played by dave
filoni the showrunner of the mandalorian
and who we previously saw in chapter 6
taking on malik's space station
they pulled over mando because he's not
running a beacon something that allows
the new republic patrol ships to see
who's in their system and if mando can't
give them the proper credentials he'll
have to be escorted to adelphi a new
republic outpost
he makes a run for it knowing his ping
will alert them to a warrant on his head
for
infiltrating the prison ship known as
balthan5
we saw his exploits on this ship in
episode 6 when he was tasked with
rescuing a prisoner known as
kin mando is able to evade the x-wings
by diving through the atmosphere of the
ice planet maldo-crace
but the strain on his ship is too much
and it crash lands among a frozen cave
system
according to wookipedia this is the same
ice planet we saw in
episode 1 where mando escaped a vicious
ravenic and baby oda eats another egg
with nowhere to go mando suggests they
sleep while they can but lady frog's
time is precious
she's on her final breeding cycle and if
she doesn't get these eggs delivered on
time they'll die
so she uses the dismantled droid 0 who
tried to kill baby yoda back in chapter
6
to communicate with mando letting him
know that it's part of his code to
fulfill his
end of their deal i thought honoring
one's work was a part of the mandalorian
code
while fixing the ship the child alerts
mando that frog lady has strayed away so
he uses his predator-like scan to follow
her footprints to an underwater hot
spring i mean come on mando give her
some privacy we saw mando use this
tracking technique in chapter 4 when he
has his first run-in with cara dune
the frog lady base her eggs in the hot
spring probably because the energy on
her egg container has been losing steam
and my first thought about this cave was
that we'd have an encounter with a wampa
the yeti-like creature luke skywalker
almost died from in
empire strikes back but oh no we have
something
much worse as baby yoda goes on his
quest to eat anything egg-shaped he
unleashes a swarm of ice spiders
spiders that come in all shapes and
sizes including this giant one now this
isn't the first time these spiders have
been created for star wars in fact they
were originally planned to be roaming
dagobah
in concept art for the empire strikes
back that idea was scrapped but they
were later seen in star wars
rebels where they became known as krykna
mando and frog lady get the hell out of
dodge and we even see frog lady have to
hop
on all fours to outrun the massive
plague of spiders
mando himself has to use many of his
tools to escape including thermal
grenades flamethrower van braces and his
blaster they make it to the cockpit when
an
absolute giant spider looks to make
quick work of them when they're suddenly
saved by those two republic fighter
pilots from earlier they've tracked
mando down
and come to his rescue agreeing to
eliminate the warrant for his arrest
considering what he did way back in
chapter 6.
apparently security reports show that
the mandalorian was integral in bringing
down three priority culprits from the
wanted register as well
it showed his efforts to protect
lieutenant davin you may remember daven
as being the only humanoid crew member
on the prison ship
he was killed by the twilak mercenary
gian in exchange for erasing his warrant
they want mando to make sure his
transponder is fixed
so the next time he's in the system they
won't vaporize him and with the ship
barely able to make it out they continue
on to the estuary moon of trask with
only the cockpit of the razor crest
pressurized for space travel so it looks
like next episode will be on this new
planet a planet which apparently has a
mandalorian covenant where he might get
answers about both baby yoda
and the boba fett armor will we see boba
next episode and is moff gideon still on
its tracks
we'll just have to wait next week to
find out thanks for watching everyone if
you liked the video be sure to give it a
like
subscribe and share with your friends
you can also follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much